we're going to start with breaking news
out of Gabon senior members of the
military are set to have appeared on
television saying they are now in
control of the country they've also
announced the cancellation of Elections
and all institutions have been dissolved
gabon's electoral commission said that
President Ali Bongo had won a third term
in a controversial ballot held in the
last few days he's said to have got
nearly 65 percent of the vote well that
statement has appeared on X formerly
known as Twitter ostensibly from the
military saying after noting an
irresponsible and unpredictable
governance which results in a continuous
deterioration of social cohesion that
risks leading the country to chaos in
the name of the gabonese people we the
committee for transition and restoration
of Institutions have decided to defend
the peace putting an end to the regime
in place the borders now are closed for
more or less we're going to bring in
Catherine sawy who's following
developments for us from Nairobi in
Kenya Catherine what more do you know
yes I've just been talking to some
people people who are currently in Gabon
about what is going on there's a lot of
uncertainty there's a lot of tension as
well so what we know is that the Army
has released this statement uh on Gabon
TV it's a state-run TV station based
within the presidency and as those who
addressed that made that address are
members of the um the Army and the
presidential guard as well and they call
themselves the committee for the
transition and restitution of the
institution and they say that they don't
believe that the election was free fair
or transparent they say that they say
that they also say that the Gabon
government has not been respecting the
will of the people for such a long time
for many years and that has to change
that of course this comes at a time when
the election the the election results
were just announced
an hour and a half ago and uh Ali Bongo
uh is safe to have won that election by
64 and his main uh competitor Albert uh
although uh us uh author uh has won has
um got uh 30 of the vote but we have
also been hearing from this uh uh
opposition leader and he had said that
he is not going to accept those results
that they have been they were rigged and
we also know that the internet uh is
still shut down it was uh it was shut
down uh over the weekend and uh coffee
was imposed as well so people are very
afraid people have been told to stay
home until the situation is sorted uh
but like I said people are afraid and
they just are watching uh whatever they
can because it's very hard for them to
access and get information that they
need so the situation uh very very tense
indeed
[Music]
do we have any idea uh Catherine where
the president Ali Bongo is at the moment
given that he is ostensibly holding a
third term as president
yes we have no idea
um the uh the military or the people who
were speaking on TV did not give any in
in in indication uh whether where the
president is is he uh in the presidency
is he in his uh presidential Palace uh
is he
um outside uh of the city libreville so
we have no idea uh things are moving
very fast uh but one thing like I said
one thing we know is that we don't know
uh where exactly uh is the president
Catherine Fernando thank you very much
indeed I know you're going to be
watching that situation for us we're
going to be checking back in with you
for viewers who are just joining us we
have breaking news out of Gabon senior
members of the military are set to have
appeared on TV we think we can see you
can see the pictures in front of you
there saying that they are now in
control of the country they've announced
the cancellation of recent elections and
all institutions have been dissolved
Gabon just held an election a few days
ago the Electoral commission has said
that the president alibongo had won a
third term he's said to have got nearly
65 of the vote as we say this is
breaking news we're going to bring you
more information this as we get it